expande y simplifica 7 x 10 al cuadrado
ok déjame hacer primero algo que está
mal la primera tentación para elevar
esto al cuadrado es decir que es igual a
7 x al cuadrado más 10 al cuadrado sí
pero esto de aquí está mal lo voy a
poner con mayúsculas y lo voy a subrayar
y de hecho lo voy a poner que está súper
mal vale súper mal y bueno a lo mejor
que puedes estar confundiendo porque si
se vale en multiplicación 7x por 10 al
cuadrado si es igual a 7x al cuadrado
por 10 al cuadrado pero es porque aquí
estamos multiplicando si estamos sumando
esto no se puede hacer esto está mal y
para ver que está mal pues tenemos que
hacerlo correctamente bueno entonces
vamos a hacerlo correctamente elevar un
número al cuadrado simplemente es
multiplicarlo por sí mismo entonces 7 x
+ 10 al cuadrado es 7 x + 10
multiplicado con 7 x + 10
entonces nos queda la multiplicación de
dos binomios así que podemos resolver la
de varias formas como utilizando foil o
la propiedad distributiva pero me
gustaría pensar este problema como un
problema un poco más general el problema
de elevar un binomio al cuadrado
entonces vamos a hacerlo así y luego
aplicamos lo que encontremos para este
problema va entonces lo que me interesa
es encontrar cuánto es a más ve además b
elevado al cuadrado ya vimos que no es
cuadrada más b cuadradas ale entonces lo
escribimos como lo que sí es más b por
amas ven a más ven y para realizar esta
operación vamos a utilizar la propiedad
distributiva lo que voy a hacer primero
es distribuir este a más b en cada uno
de estos dos términos en estoy acá y en
este de acá
entonces nos queda igual a por además ve
más ve por más
y ahora distribuir está en estos dos y
esta vez en estos dos y nos queda
cuadrada a por aysa cuadrada más ave ave
más b por a es vea pero es lo mismo que
ave podemos cambiar el orden de los
factores más b por b que es be cuadrada
simplificando nos queda a cuadrada
tenemos dos veces saben dos veces saben
y finalmente hay que sumar p cuadrada
muy bien entonces observe el patrón para
elevar un binomio al cuadrado hay que
poner el primer término al cuadrado
sumar dos veces el producto de ambos
términos y sumar el segundo término al
cuadrado muy bien vámonos a este
problema ahora sí como le tendríamos que
hacer para elevar al cuadrado 7 x + 10 a
pues 7 x b 10 y entonces nos quedaría
nos quedaría igual a ahora si el primero
al cuadrado 7 x al cuadrado más dos
veces el primero que 7 x por el segundo
más el segundo al cuadrado 10 al
cuadrado al cuadrado sale ok entonces ve
la diferencia de la respuesta correcta
con la que dijimos que está súper mal es
que además del 7 x al cuadrado y el 10
al cuadrado tiene este término de aquí
en medio que se te puede estar escapando
o bueno que se te escapa cuando lo haces
así entonces hay que tener en cuenta ese
término de enmedio que sale de hacer
todas las multiplicaciones vale bueno
déjame simplificar ya nada más para ver
qué nos queda esto es igual a 7 x al
cuadrado pues 7 al cuadrado es 49 nos
queda 49 x cuadrada porque quizá al
cuadrado es x cuadrada más 2 por 7 14
por 10 es 140 entonces sería 140 por
equis y finalmente tenemos que sumar
este término 10 al cuadrado que es 100
ok entonces la respuesta de elevar 7 x +
10 al cuadrado es 49 x cuadrada más 140
x más